bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france plus de deux cent
cinquante cinq mille personnes testées
pour un million d'habitants de la ville
de chengdu
c'est une campagne de dépistage massive
quelle est la stratégie du gouvernement
chinois
lorsque j'ai appris en lisant la presse
chinoise d'hyères c'est que
immédiatement le gouverneur de la
province le gouverneur de la province du
sichuan où se situe chengdu qui est donc
la capitale de cette province a décrété
un couvre feu provisoire
et en fait c'est que ils ont observé
c'est que les cats comme un virus
circule est surtout très activement dans
les bars et les restaurants de nuit
d'autre part parmi les personnes
infectées
il y avait une jeune fille eh bien ils
ont posé beaucoup de questions à cette
jeune fille contaminée bien sûr par le
corona virus et on a appris que dans les
quinze jours pendant 14 jours qui ont
précédé ont précédé donc les cas de
contamination
cette jeune fille était allé à une
quinzaine d'endroits différents à savoir
des bars des restaurants des nuits ou
alors et catherine et ola tir de soins
esthétiques
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose
le gouverneur de l'apprendre ce soir
april a fait très très au sérieux
déjà dans une université chinoise à la
plus importante de cette province
les professeurs ainsi que les étudiants
ont reçu l'ordre de ne plus du tout
quitter l'université donc de rester
confinés de façon provisoire
et puis jusqu'à présent on ne sait pas
trop d'où viennent ces cas de contact
nation donc c'est après la formation que
j'ai reçu c'est encore d'origine
inconnue et enfin d'après d'autres
médias
si le gouverneur de la province du
sichuan après l' affaire très au sérieux
elle c'est parce que ils veulent
absolument éviter que le cas de juan
tout est parti le coronavirus se
reproduise alors qu'en ce qui concerne
la ville de chengdu
donc on évoque un couple dans porteurs
du virus dans 7 villes de l'ouest
que sait-on sur ce couple vous évoquez
une femme jeune femme tout à l'heure
alors tout à l'heure j'ai parlé vous ne
bénéficiez d'une vingtaine d'années par
contre la presse chinoise a peu parlé de
ce couple si j'ai bien compris un saint
vous placez angers et on n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations du moins à mon
niveau
par contre ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que moi même j'ai été en chine
il y à peu près trois mois et que j'ai
pu constater sur place
comment les chinois comment les chinois
on va dire observé avec beaucoup de
rigueur
les mesures de précision si vous voulez
je peux vous en parler
elle est vive détaillez nous c'est fait
mesures c'était en
c'était le c'était en début décembre
début septembre pour des raisons
familiales j'ai réussi à avoir mon visa
d'entrée en chine parce que mon père
était très malade et il vivait à pékin
donc j'ai voulu me rendre à pékin
le problème c'est que dès qu'un et dans
la capitale chinoise et que à l'époque à
la chine
c'est encore vrai actuellement à
je voulais surtout éviter des cadres des
cas importés
donc ils ont demandé à tous les
passagers du vol air china 900 234 de ne
pas atterrir à pékin pour ceux qui
voulaient aller à pékin mme et atterrir
dans une ville qui se situe à 300 km de
pékin et canton et tard il a carrément
et on nous a demandé d'aller directement
dans un hôtel situé à l'extérieur de
cette ville qui s'appelle christine et
là on devait rester 14 jours confinés
dans cet hôtel et quand on est arrivé à
l'hôtel
la première chose c'est qu'on a reçu
lundi une mesure très détaillée très
strictes observé pendant 14 jours
et parmi ces restes humains je peux vous
en citer 5 juste pour vous faire prendre
conscience comment les chinois sont on
va dire vigilant et très strictes par
exemple tous les jours chaque chaque
personne qui disait dans cet hôtel
devait prendre une température donc deux
fois c'était deux fois par jour le matin
à 9 heures et l'après midi à 15 heures
saint michel on va pas avoir le temps de
tout détailler cette dernière question
parce que c'est vrai que vu d'ici à
beaucoup d'interrogations sur la
transparence des informations en
provenance de chine
kako qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus rapport est là transparent à
la transe transparence des informations
en provenance de chine
vous savez qu'il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations vu d'ici
la transparence ben je pense que nous on
a les informations que les autorités ou
bien voulu nous donner
après on sait que
en fait bien sûr je sais que en occident
certains médias disent que les autorités
chinoises manquent de transparence en
matière de communication d'informations
fiables est ce que c'est ça votre
question oui c'était relatifs à ce live
type bien moi je pense que ça c'est un
sujet sur lequel les médias occidentaux
aiment beaucoup spéculé alors moi ma
position sur sur point est la suivante
c'est que bien sûr les autorités
chinoises d'abord c'est veulent donner
une image de marque positive de la china
et pour cela elle elle comme elle
communique des informations à mon avis
vérifier après pour ce qui est nous si
on dit que l manque de transparence là
je pense qu'il faut des preuves
voilà si beaucoup merci beaucoup à vous
camille chaîne d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes rédactrice en chef du desk français
de mandarins tv merci à vous fin